foreign
[Music]
application enables you to support your
users to buy and sell your products or
Services depending on your needs you may
keep track of inventory manage product
descriptions or prices enable wish lists
and other functionalities along with
monitoring your app's performance
these areas take time and focus when
building an e-commerce app add
infrastructure considerations and it can
feel like there is a lot to manage for
your app to run smoothly luckily there
is a jumpstart solution that helps you
understand how to focus on your specific
needs and the decisions you need to make
for your business without having to
manage all the infrastructure you can
deploy an e-commerce web app on cloud
run in minutes and learn how to manage
all these aforementioned things in
Google Cloud before launching your full
production environment
with the development and operation of
your e-commerce app you're likely
thinking how do I update characteristics
about my inventory like a price or
description change without taking down
my website
how do I add functionality to my
eCommerce site without disrupting my
business
can I collect metrics about my app so I
know when my services are functioning or
find out when something is going wrong
and fix it
is my infrastructure set up correctly
can I trust that it will support my
application so my business can flourish
when launching an e-commerce application
there are a lot of moving Parts with
different services to implement and
manage Additionally you have the
complexity of managing the underlying
infrastructure and making sure that it
can scale up or scale down as needed
this takes time away from the most
important task focusing on your app and
business as Google Cloud developers we
know that your eCommerce site is the
lifeblood of your business we hear your
questions and concerns and ask ourselves
the same ones so we developed this
solution to help you build the right
knowledge about your application that
way you know when something is wrong how
to resolve those problems and focus on
what you need when you need it we want
you to be able to focus on your business
needs while Google Cloud takes care of
the underlying infrastructure
QR e-commerce web app on cloud run
jumpstart solution the jumpstart
solution allows you to deploy an
e-commerce app with all the necessary
resources required automatically created
and configured by Google Cloud plus the
management of that infrastructure is
handled by us giving you peace of mind
and time to focus on everything else
with this solution there are three key
areas of focus you'll learn about
one built to expand with composable
e-commerce functionalities much like an
ever-growing puzzle you can start with
the functionalities that you need like a
product catalog then Implement
additional functionality as your
business grows like a shopping cart
feature
two a decoupled architecture
it gives a view of how multiple Cloud
products work together while keeping the
core application to two moving Parts
making it easier to scale make changes
without disrupting your business
three data-driven insights using logs
trace and error reporting you'll learn
how to collect insights that help you
fully understand how your business is
running and manage any problems that
arise deploying the solution takes a
matter of minutes and provides access to
a front-end UI and back-end experience
for a sample e-commerce product website
once deployed you can access the web app
like a user and click on products add
them to a cart and make a purchase
then you can explore the app as an
administrator modify the list of
products or customize prices and see the
changes reflected in the front end
or you can explore the deployment which
consists of multiple primary services
that have been integrated into a single
application you can review successful
purchases and errors which we'll talk
about more in a second modify the source
code for a back-end service and redeploy
the backend Service as needed let's
touch on those successful purchases and
errors
this is where you begin to see the inner
workings of the solution
each time a purchase is attempted
whether successful or not it's logged in
the Google Cloud console in Cloud
logging and error reporting in the form
of two errors or a success condition
these conditions were intentionally
created to facilitate the process of
learning how you can use the included
Google Cloud products to analyze your
data by tracking user actions that
matter collecting insights and dealing
with errors as needed think of this as
the big dress rehearsal before the show
you can practice and see how everything
works before opening day
have a new feature you want to implement
but aren't sure how it's going to work
great test it out here first and see
what metrics you can collect to
determine if you want to move forward
with deploying it in your app or forget
you ever had the idea
once the solution is deployed the
architecture includes the following
components
the client front end is hosted on
Firebase and uses lit and web components
for client-side rendering of API data
the web client calls an API backend that
is running as a cloud run service using
the Django rest framework written in
Python Cloud run automatically scales
your infrastructure up and down as
needed
the configuration and other secrets for
the python application are stored in
secret manager static assets for the
application and container images are
stored in cloud storage and Cloud SQL
for postgres is the database for the
python application Cloud logging stores
logs cloudtrace stores open Telemetry
traces and error reporting stores error
reports all sent by other Cloud products
and the cloud run platform this data is
what enables monitoring for the correct
application behavior and troubleshooting
the unexpected Behavior
the decoupled architecture as designed
here is what allows edits to be made to
the front-end store with minimal
disruptions to your business this allows
you to separate user experience business
logic and business operations into
separate organizational concerns
to dig deeper into the solution explore
the application using our learning
resources
the solution guide is a helpful resource
to further customize the solution if you
want more information on deploying the
app or if you run into any issues
for additional Hands-On learning you can
check out our interactive tutorials
which allow you to explore and analyze
app usage with Cloud logging and
cloudtrace to monitor user requests and
spot errors and explore the back end of
the solution to make changes
it's important to note that this
jumpstart solution is a great way to
explore the capabilities of building an
e-commerce app on cloud run but isn't
intended to be used as is for production
environments
so now you know this jumpstart solution
helps you learn how to build an
e-commerce web app on cloud run with
fully managed infrastructure that allows
you to focus on your business check the
description for a few very useful links
to try out this jumpstart solution for
yourself today
foreign
[Music]